let me welcome you again to to this
joint session of the world leaders forum
and the conference on a new form of
capitalism that's been organised with
the University of Duffing in Paris we're
really fortunate this afternoon to have
a talk from George Soros most of you
know a great deal about mr. Soros but
let me talk about two things that you
may not know he is the author of 11
books and many of these books have some
very interesting ideas both for changing
ideas about how economies function and
about the global political framework one
book that I I had a opportunity to
review was his book on globalization one
other important set of ideas the set of
idea is called reflexivity that's been a
number of his books and his most recent
book is his lectures at the Central
European University which he founded the
other thing is that mr. Soros is georges
georges really probably the 21st century
most important philanthropist he began
his philanthropy back in nineteen
seventy-nine when he began providing
funds to help black students attend Cape
Town University in apartheid South
Africa he established a network of
philanthropy traffic organizations
active in more than 50 countries around
the world these organizations are
dedicated promoting the values of
democracy and open society and more
recently George has been involved in
trying to change something equally
difficult which is changing the
economics profession and in the creation
of
the institute for new economic thinking
but also more recently also been in some
of the work that he's most proud of is
work on climate change in indonesia so
without any further ado let me ask
George to come here Thank you Thank
22 years have passed since the crash of
2008 I've written some books where I
explained what happened then I think
it's time to bring the story up to date
and that's what I propose to do today
the theory I use is this is the same as
in previous books so I won't repeat it
here the main points to remember our
first that rational human beings don't
base their decisions on reality but on
their understanding of reality and the
two are never the same although the
extent of the divergence varies and the
variance is what really matters this is
the principle of fail ability a second
the participants misconceptions as
expressed in market prices effect the
so-called fundamentals which market
prices are supposed to reflect and
that's the principle of reflexivity the
two of them together assure that both
market participants and regulators have
to make the decisions in conditions of
uncertainty this is the human
uncertainty principle it implies that
outcomes are unlikely to correspond to
expectations and markets are unable to
ensure the optimal allocation of
resources these implications are in
direct contradiction to the theory of
rational expectations and the efficient
market hypothesis and markets basically
justice
brune to create self-reinforcing
initially self-reinforcing but
eventually self-defeating Boombah
sequences or bubbles just as likely to
do that as to tend towards equilibrium
so so much for theory now for the actual
course of events in the in the crash of
2008 the uncertainties reached such an
extreme that the markets actually
collapsed but that was a temporary
temporary phenomenon because the
authorities intervened and managed to
keep markets functioning by putting them
on artificial life support in retrospect
the momentary collapse may seem like a
bad dream but it was real enough and two
years later we still suffer from its
consequences let me explain why when a
car is kidding you have to turn the
wheel in the same direction as the skid
to prove to prevent the car from
crashing only when you have regained
control can you correct the direction of
the car and that's how the financial
authorities had to deal with the crash
the underlying cause of the crash was
the excessive use of credit and leverage
to prevent a catastrophe they had to
avoid a sharp contraction of credit the
only way to do it was to replace the the
private credit that had lost credibility
with the credit of the state we still
commanded respect
only after financial markets resume
functioning could they hope to reverse
course and reduce the outstanding credit
and leverage this meant that they had to
do in the short term the exact opposite
of what would be needed in the long term
now the first phase of this delicate
maneuver has now been successfully
completed financial markets are
functioning more or less normally with
toxic credit instruments replaced or
guaranteed by a sovereign credit but the
second phase is running into
difficulties before the economy has
fully recovered and unemployment has
fallen the credibility of sovereign
credit has come into question if
governments are now forced to pursue
fiscal discipline and tighten monetary
and fiscal policy too soon there is a
danger that the recovery will abort that
is because the imbalances that have
accumulated over a quarter of a century
have not yet been corrected the u.s.
still consumes too much and China still
running a unsustainable export surplus
visibly the United States a similar
imbalance prevails within the eurozone
with Germany in the surplus position in
addition the housing and commercial real
estate bubbles in the US have not yet
been fully deflated and in the eurozone
the banks have not yet been properly
recapitalized the deleveraging of the
private sector is underway but it's far
from complete in the u.s. it applies to
bank
corporations and consumers alive in
Europe it's heavily concentrated in the
banking sector because the global
imbalances still remain to be corrected
the question arises how much government
is to govern and that is too much and
that's the central question confronting
policymakers today the discussion is
eerily reminiscent of the 1930s then the
fiscal conservatives led by Andrew
Mellon and irving fisher were confronted
by rebels like john maynard keynes now
the division of opinion is more along
national lines the center of financial
conservatism is Germany while those who
have rediscovered canes are located
mainly in the United States The Clash of
views has led to a drama which is
unfolding differently in different parts
of the world the remarkable unanimity
that prevailed in the first phase of
global crisis and culminated in the one
trillion dollar rescue package that was
put together for the London meeting of
the g20 in april two thousand nine has
dissipated and political and ideological
differences have a reason misconceptions
are rampant they complicate the matter
enormously because because it would
require global cooperation to correct
the global imbalances I shall briefly
review
how the credibility of sovereign decade
it came to be questioned in various
parts of the world and then I shall
address the question how much that is
too much doubts concerning sovereign
credit first reached a crisis point in
Europe and they devolved around the euro
but what appeared to be a currency
crisis was in reality more a banking
crisis and a clash of economic
philosophies the euro was an incomplete
currency to start with the maastricht
treaty established a monetary union
without a political union the Euro
boosted a common central bank but it
lacked a common Treasury so even though
member countries share a common currency
when it comes to sovereign credit they
are on their own unfortunately this fact
was obscured until recently by the
willingness of the European Central Bank
to accept sovereign debt of all member
countries on equal terms at its discount
window this allowed the member countries
to borrow it practically the same
interest rates as Germany and the banks
were happy to earn a few extra pennies
on supposedly risk-free assets by
loading up their balance sheets with the
government debt of the weaker currencies
for instance Europe European banks
called more than a trillion euros or
Spanish that of which more than half is
held by German and French banks the
large positions came to endanger the
creditworthiness of the European banking
system depriving them of the capacity to
add to their position
although it was the inability of the
bank to continue buying the government
debt of the heavy indebted countries
that precipitated the crisis it was
really the introduction of the euro and
the ECB's willingness to refinance
sovereign debt that got the banks
weighed down with these large positions
in the first place it led to a radical
narrowing of interest rate differentials
and that in turn create generated real
estate bubbles in countries like Spain
Greece and Ireland instead of the
convergence prescribed by the Maastricht
Treaty these countries grew faster and
developed trade deficits within the
eurozone while Germany reined in is
labor costs became more competitive and
developed a chronic trade surplus the
discount facility of the ECB allowed the
deficit countries to continue borrowing
practically the same rates as Germany
relieving them of any pressure to
correct their excesses so the
introduction of the euro was in Turin
indirectly responsible for the
development of internal imbalances
within the eurozone the first clear
reminder that the Euro lacked a common
Treasury came after the bankruptcy of
lehman brothers the finance ministers of
the european union promised that no
other financial institution whose
failure could endanger as a system would
be allowed to default but angela merkel
opposed a joint europe-wide guarantee
each country had to take care of its own
banks at first the banks the financial
markets were so impressed by the
guarantee that they hardly notice the
difference
capital fled from the countries which
were not in a position to offer similar
guarantees pushing the countries of
Eastern Europe notably Hungary and the
Baltic States into difficulties but
interest rates differentials within the
eurozone remained minimal the only this
year that financial market started to
worry it was Greece that started the
process when the newly elected
government revealed that the previous
government had lied about the deficit
for 2009 and was much larger than he
indicated markets panicked and interest
rate differentials widen dramatically
but the European authorities were slow
to react because member countries held
radically different views Germany which
had been traumatized by two episodes of
runaway inflation was adamantly opposed
to any bailout France was more willing
to show it is solidarity since Germany
was heading into elections it was
unwilling to act and nothing could be
done without Germany so the Greek crisis
festered and spread when the authorities
finally got their act together they had
to offer a much larger rescue package
there would have been necessary as it ed
acted earlier in the meantime doubts
spread to the other deficit countries
and in order to reassure the markets the
authorities had to put together a 750
euro of European financial stabilization
fund 500 million of billion of which
came from the Member States and 250 from
the IMF the turning point came when
China we entered the market and bought
Spanish bonds and the Euro so under
duress the euro has begun to remedy its
main shortcoming the lack of a common
Treasury the Stabilization Fund is very
far from a unified fiscal policy but
it's a step in the right direction
member countries are now a little bit
pregnant and they will be obliged to
take additional steps so the crisis has
passed its high watermark and the euro
is here to stay but it's far too early
to celebrate because the emerging common
fiscal policy is dictated by Germany and
Germany is wedded to a false doctrine of
macroeconomic stability which recognizes
only the threat of inflation and ignores
the possibility of deflation this
misconception is incorporated in the
constitution of the euro when Germany
agreed to substitute the euro for large
mark it insisted on strong safeguards to
maintain the value of the currency and
that's how the ECB was given an
asymmetric directive requiring it only
to fight inflation moreover the massive
treaty contains a clause that expressly
expressly prohibits bailouts and this
has been reaffirmed by the German
Constitutional Court is this cause
clause that has made the crisis so
difficult to deal with this brings me to
the gravest effect of the euros design
it doesn't allow for error it expects
member states to abide by the maastricht
treaty without establishing an adequate
enforcement mechanism and now when
practically all member countries have
violated the Maastricht criteria there
is neither an adjustment mechanism nor
an exit mechanism and the country can
tell the countries are expected to
return to the massive criteria in short
order what's worse Germany is not only
insisting on strict fiscal discipline
for the weaker countries but it's also
reducing its own fiscal deficit when
both editor and debtor countries are
reducing deficits at the same at a time
of high unemployment they set in motion
a deflationary spiral in debtor
countries reductions in employment tax
receipts and consumption reinforce each
other and are not offset by exports
raising the prospect that deficit
reduction targets will not be met and
further reductions will be required and
even if budgetary targets were met is
difficult to see how the weaker
countries could regain their
competitiveness vasavi Germany and start
growing again because in the absent in
the absence of exchange rate
depreciation they need to cut wages and
prices creating deflation and deflation
renders the burden of accumulated that
even heavier deficit reduction by
accredited creditor countries such as
Germany is in direct contradiction of
the lessons learned from the Great
Depression of the 1930s is liable to put
push Europe into a period of prolonged
seg nation of us that may in turn
produce social unrest and since the
unpopular policies are imposed from the
outside turn public opinion against the
European Union so the Euro with this
asymmetric directive may endanger the
social and political cohesion of Europe
unfortunately Germany is unlikely to
realize that is following the wrong
macroeconomic policy because that policy
is actually working to his advantage
Germany is the shining star in the
economic firmament he dealt with the
burden of reunification by reducing his
labor costs becoming more competitive
and developing a chronic trade surplus
and Europe crisis brought about a
decline in the value of the euro this
favorite Germany against its main
competitor Japan and in the second
quarter of 2010 the GDP Trump by nine
percent annualize Germany believes is
doing the right thing it has no desire
to impose its will on Europe or it wants
to do is to maintain this
competitiveness and avoid becoming the
deep pocket to the rest of Europe but as
the strongest had most creditworthy
country it's in the driver's seat as a
result Germany object objectively
determines the financial and
macroeconomic policies of the eurozone
without being subjectively aware of it
and the political policies it is
imposing are liable to to send the
eurozone into a deflationary spiral
but people in Germany are unlikely to
recognize this because they are doing
much better than the others and the
difficulties of the others can be blamed
on structural rigidities the German
commitment to fiscal rectitude is also
gaining the upper hand in the rest of
the world unto the macro went into the
GCF into the recent g20 meeting in the
minority and with the help of Canada and
the newly elected conservative British
Prime Minister that David Cameron came
out as the winner prior to the meeting
President Obama publicly appealed to
Chancellor and macro to change her ways
but AB de meeting the yes sided with the
majority and agreed that budget deficits
should be cut in half by 2 2013 this may
be the right policy but it comes at the
wrong time the policies of the Obama
administration are dictated not by
financial necessity but by political
considerations the u.s. is under the
same is not under the same pressure from
the bond markets as the heavy rain that
is states of europe european debtor
countries have to pay hefty premiums
over the price at which Germany can
borrow by contrast interest rates on the
US and US government bonds have been
falling and our near record law lord
knows this means that financial markets
anticipate deflation rather than
inflation the pressure is entirely
political the public is deeply troubled
by the accumulation of public debt the
Republican opposition
has succeeded in blaming the crash of
2008 and the subsequent recession and
persistent high unemployment and the
ineptitude of the government and in
claiming that the similis package was
largely wasted there is an element of
truth in this narrative but is far too
one-sided the crash of 2008 was
primarily market failure and failure the
private sector and the fault of the
regulator's was that they fail to
regulate without the ABE bailout the
financial system would have stayed
paralyzed and the subsequent recession
would have been much longer and deeper
is true that the stimulus was law was
largely spent on consumption and didn't
correct the underlying in imbalances but
that was because of time pressure as I
explained earlier the government was
obliged to do in the short run the exact
opposite of what is needed in the long
run now consumption still needs to fall
as a percentage of the GDP and fiscal
and monetary stimulus are still needed
to keep the GDP from falling and to
prevent a deflationary spiral where the
Obama administration did go wrong in my
opinion was in the way it bailed out the
banking system it helped the banks earn
their way out of a hole by supplying
them with cheap money and relieving them
of some of their best bad SS but this
was an entirely political decision and a
strictly economic calculation it would
have been more effective to inject new
equity into the balance sheets of the
but the Obama administration considered
that politically unacceptable because it
would amount to nationalizing the banks
and we would have been called socialism
the polluted political decision
backfired and caused a serious political
backlash the public so that the banks
earn bumper profits and pay large
bonuses while they were squeezed by the
credit card charges jumping from eight
percent to nearly twenty thirty percent
that was the source of the resentment
that the Tea Party exploited so
successfully in Boston in addition the
administration has deployed the
so-called confidence multiplier to
restore confidence and that to
disappointment when unemployment failed
to fall the administration is now under
defensive the Republicans are
campaigning against any further stimulus
and they seem to be winning the argument
the administration feels that it has to
pay lip service to fiscal rectitude even
if it recognizes that the timing may be
premature I believe that there is a
strong case for further stimulus
admittedly the consumption can't be
sustained indefinitely by running up the
national debt the imbalance between
consumption and investment needs to be
corrected but to cut back on government
spending at a time of large-scale
unemployment would ignore all the
lessons
learned from the Great Depression the
obvious solution is to draw a
distinction in the budget between
investments and current current
consumption and increase the former
while reducing the letter but that seems
unattainable in the current political
environment a large majority of the
population is convinced that the
government is incapable of efficiently
managing an investment program aimed at
improving the physical and human
infrastructure again this belief is not
without justification a quarter of a
century of agitation calling the
government bad has resulted in bad
government but to argue the stimulus
spending is inevitably wasted it's
patently false the New Deal produced the
Tennessee Valley Authority and the
Triborough bridge and many other
utilities that are still a part of our
infrastructure it's the Obama
administration that has failed to make a
convincing case there are times like the
present when we cannot count on the
private sector to employ the available
resources the Obama administration has
in fact been very friendly to business
corporations operate very profitably but
instead of investing their profits they
are building up their liquidity perhaps
a Republican victory will give them more
confidence but interceptions investment
and employment needs to be stimulated by
the government I don't believe that
monetary policy can be successfully
substituted for fiscal policy
quantitative easing
is more likely to stimulate corporations
corporations to devour each other than
to create employment we shall soon find
out this brings me to the question I
posed earlier how much room does the
government have but for fiscal stimulus
how much public that is too much this is
not the only unresolved question but
it's at the center of political debate
and the debate is riddled with
misconceptions that is because the
fashion doesn't have a hard and fast
answer in saying this I am NOT being
evasive on the contrary I'm making am
making an important assertion the
tolerance for public that is highly
dependent on the participants
perceptions and misconception
misconceptions in other words it's
reflexive there are a number of
variables involved to start with the
debt burden is not an absolute amount
but the ratio between the debt and the
GDP the higher the GDP the smaller the
burden represented by a given amount of
debt the other important variable is the
interest rate the higher the interest
rate the heavier the debt burden in this
context the risk premium attached to the
interest rate is particularly important
once it starts rising the prevailing
rate of deficit financing becomes
unsustainable and needs to be reined in
exactly where that tipping point is
located the remains are certain because
it's dependent on prevailing attitudes
in other words it's reflexive and
therefore uncertain take the case of
Japan it's that ratio is approaching two
hundred percent one of the highest in
world yet 10-year bonds yield little
more than 1% admittedly Japan used to
have a high savings rate but it has an
aging and shrinking population and its
current scene is rate is about the same
as the u.s. the big difference is that
Japan has a trade surplus and the u.s. a
deficit but that's not such a big
difference as long as China doesn't
allow its currency to appreciate because
that policy obliges China to finance the
deficit one way or another the real
reason why Japanese interest rates are
so low is that the private sector
individuals banks and corporations have
little appetite for investing abroad and
prefer 10-year government bonds yielding
at one percent to cash a zero with the
price level falling and the population
aging the real return on such
instruments is considered attractive by
the Japanese and as long as US banks can
borrow as near zero and buy government
bonds without having to commit equity
and the dollar is not allowed to
depreciate against a ravine d interest
rates on US government bonds may well be
heading in the same direction that's not
to say that it would be sound policy for
the u.s. to maintain interest rates at
zero and preserve the current imbalances
by issuing government that indefinitely
once the economy starts growing interest
rates will rise and if the accumulated
debt is too big it may rise
precipitously choking of the recovery
but for premature fiscal tightening may
choke choke off the recovery
prematurely the right policy is to
reduce the imbalances as fast as
possible while keeping the increase in
the debt burden to a minimum this can be
done in none in a number of ways but
cutting the budget deficit in half by
2013 while the economy is operating far
below capacity is not one of them
investing in infrastructure and
education makes more sense so does
engineering a moderate rate of inflation
by depreciating the dollar against the
remainder what stands in a way are
misconceptions about budget deficits
exploited for partisan and ideological
purposes I see a real danger that the
premature pursuit of fiscal rectitude
may wreck the recovery thank
thank you very much thank you very much
George for those comics we have time for
just a few questions if you can line up
at the two microphones go ahead what's
the biggest misconception that the
average person has about money the
biggest misconception that the average
person has about money well as their
several and there's the well-known money
money illusion but in and there's also
the misconception that the debt
sovereign that is somehow necessarily
passed on from one generation to the
next if the economy is growing that a
growing deficit is not a growing debt is
is actually a not an additional burden
right now i think is this misconception
that is dominating the debate thank you
I was interested in early part of your
speech and you talked about Germany as
the conservative force and that's
exactly where I'm from and I was
wondering what were the concrete steps
the German should take to adjust the
situation your opinion thank you what
were the concrete steps that Germany
should take to correct its imbalances I
think that that it should not be
reducing his budget deficit at the
present time and also should look for
ways for stimulating the European
economy altogether the Germany situation
is very constrained by the requirement
that it has to balance is it's the
federal budget by twenty fifteen or
twenty eighteen in a number of years and
it has to move towards that that a
balanced budget over time and that is
what is pushing the reduction in the
deficit and that is what makes it
difficult to find some source of fiscal
stimulus for the European economies as a
whole and I think therefore that fiscal
stimulus has to be found within the
European Union is in one way or another
I think actually the issue of as the
arse could be a good be a very useful
step in these circumstances but that
would require quite a bit of convincing
hello mr. sorrows I'm a business school
student and a fellow philosophy major
I'm one of your lectures last year you
called for a clear distinction between
financial markets and politics but this
distinction seems less and less clear
these days so would you say that what we
have today is a political marketplace
and if so what can we do about it it was
the question of the interaction between
politics and finance and I think partly
the excess of influence of finance in
the political process in the United
States did I get that right yep yes I
mean
we have to recognize that generally
speaking misconceptions play a very very
important in shaping history and it's
particularly true in fact what you might
call financial history and force
interpretations of reality exert a
remarkably far-reaching influence that
is actually the reason why I'm
sponsoring this institute for new
economic thinking because economic
theory which has the status of science
is actually i will say built on an false
premises so it's not astonishing but
it's important to understand how
important these misconceptions are in
shaping policies it's so clear what the
right policies ought to be and yet
politically they are not practical and
that's the moment that's the situation
at the moment do you want to say any
word about about how what kind of
reforms might reduce the influence of
financial markets in our political
process well that that would require
some some I think it is require actually
a
a change in ethical standards because it
is generally accepted that special
interests push for their to prevail in
legislation and and legislators are
leave money to get elected and therefore
they are very susceptible to that kind
of pressure and if you look at for
instance the financial reform act it was
really lobbied and and and the fact in
the process so it really doesn't do the
job that it required to do so the the
point I was making that respect that
while I stress that markets are
imperfect because they are unstable and
they need to be regulated I should
equally emphasize that regulations are
even more imperfect because they are
subject to two political influences and
the regulators of bureaucrats and
bureaucrats are always slow to react to
reality markets actually a much faster
in adopting to reality than the
regulator's so while you need to
regulate you also have to recognize that
the regulations are bound to be inferred
imperfect and will constantly need to be
revised in the in the light of current
developments Thank You mr. Soros I just
had a question regarding the Bank of
Japan a little over two weeks ago they
decided to direct directly intervened
into the currency market and more or
less the free markets have been eroding
away the appreciation if you could offer
your opinions about some alternatives
about their currency
japan intervened in their exchange rate
and it hasn't been sustained Andrew do
you want to comment on actually I intend
to comment that at length on under under
currency issue in the next few days
because it's the other largely
unresolved a problem that's weighing
currently on on the on the other global
economy the third one actually is
banking Greg the regulation of the
financial sector which is not
sufficiently coordinated but i think
that Japan was actually right in
intervening unilaterally because it
couldn't get international cooperation
and we are in need of a new plaza accord
type of Understanding between the major
economic powers in the world on the
relationship of currencies hey mr. Soros
um basically my question is when it
comes to the Obama administration it
seems like it's managed to alienate both
sides of the domestic economic argument
it seems like the left wanted a bigger
stimulus and thinks he brought too many
people from that world on board in terms
of his economic advisors and the right
especially Wall Street keeps saying that
he's not creating a business-friendly
environment so how can he repair that
image among both sides or at least one
side and get something done you need to
go to the left and right that is to
business and he's anti-business can he
do which can he get to save his
positioning save at least one of those
two
well I think Obama found finds himself
in a rather awkward situation because
because his rhetoric has been very
anti-business while his actions have
been very pro-business and he's getting
the belt of the worst of both these
policies because he's accused of being
Antipas as far as in fact his policies
have been very much to to preserve the
financial system has been very
successful in making the recession of
far shorter and and and and and
shallower then it would then it would
have been otherwise by actually invoking
this confidence multiplier and
reassuring the public that unemployment
is going to fall and and and so on and
of course when that didn't happen then a
public opinion turned against him and
that is what makes his position at the
present time so difficult well I think
that that he ought to resist the the
extension of the Bush tax credits and
instead use the monies that would be
collected to stimulate the economy
through fiscal measures now that I think
is actually what is needed because
currently with the rebuilding of
liquidity that
occurring everywhere you do need this
government stimulus to get the economy
going would you mind sharing your
opinion of and prediction for the
economic government's package which is
making its way through the European
Parliament at the moment package going
making its way through the parliament in
Europe I don't know that I don't know
what the other what do yes it's the
package that's being proposed by the
economic and Monetary Affairs Committee
about the sanctions for non-compliance
with DDP to debt and the sanctions on
European countries for non-compliance to
enforce the Maastricht well it is it
this is in compliance with with the
current construction of the euro but as
I try to explain this is pushing Europe
into a deflationary stagnation or or
perhaps recession and so you need to
find some new sources of stimulation
which I think has to be europe-wide
because the individual countries do need
to
engage in the structural reforms that
are pressing so the penalties by
themselves would be okay it's the lack
of stimulus that is it that is the
problem how much Oh mr. Soros my
question will consist of two parts the
first part how do you think there will
be any transformation applied to the
concept central bank independence and
the second part of the question is where
a risk of global hyperinflation in the
current state of global financial system
which is overfilled of money printed
during the crisis did you get the first
is you v1 is central bank independence
and the second is with all the liquidity
going in is there a risk of
hyperinflation in the long run actually
the center banks are not quite as
independent as they claim to be which is
just which is a good thing and the we
are currently face the reality of
deflationary pressures and the prospect
of inflationary pressures so if you have
the fear of inflation and the reality of
of deflation and that actually is what
is weighing on on on the on the economy
unfortunately run out of time so I'm
sorry about that next time we'll get let
me let me thank mr. Soros again for a
very stimulating discussion and thank
you all for coming
you